sometimes I get so discouraged I can
hardly stand in perhaps I should seek
professional help so we've got some
questions from the mailbag we also have
Reddit this is from Casey says Dear
supreme leader and Sweet Daddy Walsh I
have a question for you about having a
large family I'm pregnant right now with
our seventh child congratulations who
appears we'll be breaking the tie in
favor of the boys team I'm about 23
weeks along my mom and dad don't know at
all they've repeatedly stated how happy
they are that I'm not pregnant yet and
uh what a wonderful thing for your
parents to say to you isn't it and they
frequently bring up the topic of birth
control and conversation just like after
every other one of our kids was born
what kind of what is
who does that first of all and I and I
say this rhetorically because I know
people do it but
telling someone I'm so happy you're not
pregnant and then also these are your
parents are they not happy to have
grandkids what I've explained to my
mother how badly I feel about the way
they talk about it she just says that
she's concerned because of my age 31
okay 31 is not that old and because I
tend to be kind of stressed I personally
feel like that comes with the territory
and she should know so she had four kids
we get mostly negative comments from
everyone we know and most strangers too
even people who are Christians which I
find to be the most surprising my
husband and I feel we have been blessed
with a large family we wouldn't want to
trade them in for anything but it seems
everyone else is very unhappy with us
for feeling that way we don't personally
know any other large families either how
do you and your wife cope with stuff
like this or were you able to find
people who have no issue with your
family being so big by today's standards
if so how would you suggest I find such
a community specifically I don't have
any close friends and we haven't had
much luck at churches at least not yet
okay well
as far as finding a network or finding
people that have large families church
is going to be the way to go one way you
know you found a good one is uh if it's
a church with lots of young and growing
families you find a church like that
then that's a good church for you if you
haven't found that yet then I would keep
looking how do I deal with it in my own
family well I will admit I have a
certain Advantage with this because I I
come from a large family you know I've
got six kids I'm one of six myself I
have a sister who has 10 kids okay so I
mean we've got like I think there are 30
something nieces and nephews now so for
me I don't have to worry about if
anything I get I'm going to get judged
in my family for not having enough kids
six kids in my family those like rookie
numbers thump those numbers up those are
rookie numbers in this racket but in
society right I'm in the same society as
you are and uh yeah I hear the snide
comments I see the looks people give you
how do I deal with it I just don't care
at all I mean you have to get to a point
where it doesn't mean anything to you
um the fact that people are judging you
or don't approve of how many kids you
have who gives a damn you have too many
kids frankly my hair I don't give a damn
it becomes a lot easier to not give a
damn which should be your correct
attitude when you understand why they
feel this way like why are they judging
you for having a large healthy happy
family the only way that it would be
appropriate to judge someone for having
a lot of kids is like if it's a woman
who has you know nine kids by five
different fathers
okay well there's gonna be some judgment
that comes with that or if you're one of
the fathers that's got kids with a bunch
of different women thanks to me the
world now has eight billion people but a
large intact happy family
that is that is led by a a father and a
mother who are married judging that or
having any negative opinion about that
is absurd but the reason why they judge
it and have a negative opinion it's Envy
that's what it is they're envious of it
you are happy
in a way that they can't conceive of or
understand you're happy in a way that
challenges them and makes them feel
uncomfortable with their own decisions
so maybe in the case of your parents
maybe your mother in particular because
it sounds like she's the one who's
making these comments she was uh kind of
Miserable as as a mother with younger
kids she couldn't figure out how to get
out of her own way and stop being so
selfish and self-centered and so she was
just sulking about it and yet you have
embraced even more kids and you're
finding joy in it and so she feels
almost attacked by that so I think once
you realize what's behind that um those
uh harsh judgments from people it
becomes easier to ignore it and if
anything to feel sorry for them from
Anonymous hey man I'm 27 years old I met
my fiance a little over 13 years ago
almost two years ago I finally got the
courage to ask her to be my girlfriend
six months ago I asked her to be my wife
we both said from the beginning that we
wanted to put God first and we do not
want to live together and we have not
slept together we're about three months
away from our wedding I continue to love
her more and more every day I love her
in ways I didn't know you could love
someone as we get closer closer to our
wedding I find myself continually
getting more nervous and there's
constant fear of failing as a husband
and a father are these normal feelings
to have as a young man about to start a
family of his own and if so do you have
any advice on how to overcome this yes
their normal feelings for a young man
about to start a family you ask how to
overcome it
I'm not even sure if that's the right
phrasing I don't know if that's how I
would look at it I think the the fear of
failure uh the fear of not living up to
expectations
the fear of
not performing your duties as you're
supposed to perform them I think that's
good that's now you don't want to be
over overcome by it you don't want to be
consumed by it all the time you
certainly don't want to walk around
Sullen and and feeling uh put upon by it
and complaining about it you don't want
to do any of that but if you have that
fear and it drives you to succeed
and it makes you
uncomfortable in a good way I don't see
it as a as a Bad Thing many people have
almost the opposite problem they're numb
to that fear of failure they don't care
anymore and we don't fear failure enough
you end up failing do you need a gift
for Valentine's Day well then you need
genucel skin care for the first time
ever every order at genucel.com from now
until Valentine's Day includes a free
Beauty Box with two luxury gifts they
just introduced their new microbiome
moisturizer which uses the power of
probiotics to Target skin redness pesky
wrinkles Fine Lines patchy blotches and
other signs of premature aging these are
the same probiotics that are in your
yogurt as it turns out probiotics are
not just good for digestion they can
have the same nourishing benefits on
your skin you can see results in 12
hours or get your money back guaranteed
my talent manager Tessa uses genucel
under eye treatment to help get rid of
the bags under eyes that she claims are
my fault for working her so hard right
now you can get genusel's most popular
package for 70 off as well as your two
free luxury gifts visit genucel.com
Walsh and get 70 off with your free
gifts use code wall should check out to
have this applied to your account that's
genucel.com Welsh genucel.com Welsh from
Tatum says Dear Matt long time listener
are much like your lovely wife I too
have a curmudgeonly dark-headed and
bearded man in my life he is particular
and convicted much like yourself I adore
him love him and very much find it
amusing how playful and Goofy I can be
in respect to his adorable severity my
only concern is his tendency to be
pessimistic when things go badly in his
life we both are Catholic I've often
heard you cite the unavoidable reality
of suffering and life what advice could
you give me when my bearded curmudgeon
gets into his woe as me moods I don't
find it attractive and it makes me feel
helpless to ease his Strife as he seems
to so resigned to being the victim of
undue struggle how can I help him accept
the that the world is not out to get him
and that he needs to implement a more
grateful and accepting outlook on life
even when it doesn't seem fair I know
better than anyone that when it rains it
pours I want him to feel the same
freedom I also hope I explain this
adequately I think you did and actually
this hopefully is very helpful for
anyone else listening to this other men
hearing this because one of the lies
that we hear from society is that we
should be as men you know we won't be
very emotional all the time and you
don't want to keep anything in let
people know how you're feeling and as I
have often said that is not the way to
live as a man doesn't mean you keep
everything bottled up all the time or
you can never tell anyone about your
feelings
but as men were not meant to walk around
wearing off our emotions on our sleeves
all the time much less letting our
motions get the better of us
stoicism is a very much a lost virtue
but that's how men are supposed to
behave it was we're supposed to carry
the burdens of life and of providing for
our families and all that kind of stuff
carry it with a certain dignity and
certainly not looking for pity from
people and as is indicated here there's
like nothing that women find less
attractive than someone who's pouting
and feeling sorry self-pity self-pity
from a man is probably the least
attractive thing to a woman because it's
the it's the exact opposite of what she
needs and wants but back to your issue
you know I would start by telling him
that his conviction and his seriousness
of purpose which you mentioned at the
top you find that not only attractive
but it's something that you lean on and
you depend on but what you need him
to do is to adopt that same approach to
the difficulties in life that you you
want you need to be able to depend on
him and you already do depend on him so
much but when he gets into these solid
sulky kind of pouty self-pitying moods
uh it it makes you feel like unstable
and you can't depend on him and I would
Express all that to him finally this one
is from Reddit I'm in love with my best
friend but we are both married and can't
be together I have a best friend and I
think he loves me too being around him
is just too painful I've known him since
we were young and our families are all
friends and very close being away from
him is heartbreaking as well no one has
the effect on me that he does everything
from the way his mind works to his hands
his the sight of his skin his smell
intoxicates me I've pulled away before
in the past and it's like I'm dead
inside every day away from him is
killing me I'm pretty sure he loves me
too we both have spouses I think it's
added at the end of the parable it's
like well we both have spouses anyway it
isn't fair to those around us I don't
know what to do how can doing the right
thing make me so unhappy when it feels
like a punishment is it better to have
him as a friend and suffer in this way I
try to push it down as well and haven't
found a happy medium has anybody been
through this what's the best way long
term okay this is a great example first
of all of why men and women cannot be
best friends okay
um especially when you're married man
people can't have friends okay you're
not married then you know that's maybe
part of the courting process and all
that but
when you're married
you should not have close friends who
are of the opposite sex you're just
asking for this it's what you it's like
you're literally asking for you might as
well ask for it out loud that doesn't
mean that you can't have Associates or
people that you work with people you're
friendly with and all that sort of thing
it doesn't mean that uh you know if
you're married and a person of the
opposite sex walks into the room you
gotta run out of the room screaming no
one is saying that but to have a close
friend to have someone you describe as a
best friend of the opposite sex when
you're married is well on your way to an
affair already
what do you do about this well there are
a few ways
you can go here there are a few
approaches one is that you could have an
affair I mean that's one potential
option that and this is something many
people end up doing and you betray
everyone around you and all of your
lives Fall Apart so that would be the
consequence there you have the affair
and all of your lives fall apart or you
could divorce your spouse and then start
a relationship with this other person
who's your soul mate and your best
friend and you love them so much and
you're intoxicated by their presence
um you can do that the person that you
pledged your undying loyalty to uh till
death do you part you've betrayed that
person you've tossed them aside
um simply because you prefer this other
person because you're emotionally
infatuated with them and now you're
starting a relationship with this other
person and the relationship has has it
begins in disloyalty you are with
someone who you know from the beginning
is a disloyal liar a liar
oh I I'm sure you don't meet a liar
that's what binds you together that's
what you most have in common with each
other is that you're both disloyal and
you you were willing to throw away the
most important promise that you both
made to other people in order to follow
your emotional impulses so we've got two
two options here already we've gone over
and both of them are near certain to
destroy your lives which leads you to
the third option which is that you cut
this person out of your life completely
you end any silly notion that they're
your best friend uh you don't see them
anymore you don't talk to them anymore
you don't have any kind of relationship
with them whatsoever and you recommit
yourself to your spouse the person that
you have that has committed himself to
you the person that you owe yourself to
and that's what you do how can doing the
right thing make me so unhappy this
person claims to be 38 years old how are
you 38 years old still saying ridiculous
things like that how can doing the right
thing make you unhappy and
welcome to the world Welcome to the Real
World Welcome To Life as a human being
yeah sometimes doing the right thing
will not be immediately satisfying to
you not only is that sometimes the case
but that's almost always the case the
joy and satisfaction of doing the right
thing it's not that it's not existent
it's that it's a it's a deeper Joy it's
more real
it's more vibrant but it means you gotta
you have to earn it
so grow the hell up in conclusion all
right we'll uh leave it there and talk
to you tomorrow grow the hell up and do
something useful really I could do that
oh I'm so excited by that idea no one
ever mentioned that before